why the need for so much gruesome
graphic violence why not let us imagine
that because it's so much fun Jan get it
oh really okay I'd like to see you walk
down the street and get attacked by some
kids who've just seen you know but you
saw me see Jan you're all messed up
because you're talking about real life
oh I'm talking about the movies now if
you want to talk about the movies we'll
talk about the movies
kids at 12 can tell the difference you
tell their parents
I Saw movies when I was a kid all right
I saw the all the movies that I'm facing
my movies are the movies that start as a
kidding yes kids go to a movie theater
they can tell the difference maybe you
couldn't when you were a kid but I could
you're doing well obviously I'm having a
great time making a terrific movie that
people are having fun seeing maybe not
you but you know what Jan I don't think
I made it for you I bet you didn't and
I'm glad you didn't well don't worry
about that baby all right Clinton well
look it's your genre